[Musique]
cyrille melchior président du
département et olivier hoarau maire du
port ont signé le pacte de solidarité
territoriale ce mercredi 25 juillet un
dispositif doté d'un budget total de 90
millions d'euros répartis entre les 24
communes de l'île
je suis heureux comme je l ai dit d'être
ici au port parce que c'est une commune
qui porte un dynamisme économique
mais en même temps comme toutes les
communes elle aussi elle connaît des
difficultés d'ordre social et nous
appartient de mutualiser nos moyens de
renforcer l'efficacité de nos actions
c'est pour cela que je signe cet après
midi avec beaucoup de plaisir ce tract
avec monsieur le maire de la commune du
port un pacte signé pour la période de
2018 à 2020 qui représentera plus de 3
millions d'euros de budget
d'investissement auxquels s'ajouteront
600 mille euros de budget de
fonctionnement
treize projets d'investissement en
faveur de la ville du port vont
bénéficier de ce pacte de solidarité
territoriale
ce pacte de solidarité signifie qu'on va
pouvoir figer une enveloppe à la fin d'
investissement et en fonctionnement
parce que c'est important aujourd'hui de
contractualiser entre collectivités
compte tenu de la situation nationale où
le gouvernement est en train de
ratiboiser sur la hache contraindra
tibo'z et sur l'accession à la propriété
donc voilà là où on doit mettre l'accent
où on doit mettre la priorité c'est ce
qu'on fait et c'est ce qu'on a fait avec
ce pacte de solidarité
c'est par solidarité territoriale
viendra renfoncer effectivement notre
ccas et ça viendra aussi compléter la
convention kaki été mis en place
très récemment c'est à dire en 2017 et
c'est un outil d'autres sociétale et ce
et sociale en faveur des personnes
démunies
voilà aujourd'hui cette signature a on a
montré l'importance et l'intérêt de cet
outil en faveur de ce public qui a l'a
vraiment besoin effectivement au port la
population en a vraiment besoin de ça tu
dis pour subvenir à ses besoins
quotidiennement les élus se sont ensuite
rendus à la maison des seniors du port
qui grâce au pacte de solidarité
territoriale mettra en place un projet
d'accessibilité numérique en faveur des
personnes âgées
[Musique]